do you like questioning your
intelligence then do I have the thing
for you
riddle are you good at riddle solving
not drunk at all riddles
I'm not I can't really think outside the
box I hate solving riddles sober - I'm
gonna there's a box I'm over here for
the riddle dead center
who likes riddles dr. Seuss no he likes
rhymes bridge trolls okay fine weird
controls what is the what is the
beginning of the end the end of time and
space and surrounds every place the sky
[Music]
there do you know what it is infinity
right the universe space a circle the
end of time and space is through the
every place the border no because there
is no end to time and space so it's
infinite you don't want to say I wanna
know why a letter around every place
it's the beginning of the end and faith
surrounds every place aha it's also
infinity there should be quotations
around this and that's why it's a
[ __ ] note your friend is an improper
sentence Lamanna logic not a man of
nonsense just cuz I'm smarter when I
drink wine doesn't make me a bad person
we don't number two I run but never walk
i mama mama but I don't I have a bed but
I don't sleep I have a month but I don't
okay stream to me it feels like a
garbage truck the cars running doesn't
walk why are you so good at riddles dude
I'm not good at a lot of things let me
have one thing what runs diarrhea you're
but if you paid bad food okay that's all
they're Riverbend all right where you
got that so fast we don't even have
jokes about it you and just make fun of
Kate because she's not figuring it out i
murmur I don't talk but it's like the
engine have a bed bed of a truck I have
a mouse but I don't eat there all right
garbage truck garbage truck what is it
we're crushing this I believe you got
one wrong I believe I'm crushing it
we're a team
riddles hard but fun if forced to do
them I will rise to the occasion and she
sure enough did and I am
[Music]